tous les hommes politiques ont à peu
près les mêmes idées et que tous pensent
exactement à peu près ce qu'il faut
faire mais la différence est là nous
devons nous adapter et eux mêmes doivent
s'adapter c'est que la différence va se
faire sur la façon de le faire
[Musique]
c'est à dire sur le style c'est super
man sur le plan permet d'apporter mois
mais la dépense et peut se faire sur les
robes et la porte à une passe qui
existent non parce qu'il ya manier et
manière d'apporter ses remèdes il ya la
manière lente douce
qui qui est plutôt prudente et il ya la
manière en forme de rupture avec l'un
des otages mais si ça change beaucoup ça
dépend vraiment de fait mais si ça
dépend comment le fait c'est à dire pour
moi je n'en
ai notamment au parti socialiste on
apprend par exemple on dit réduction des
charges sociales ya deux manières de le
faire
quand elle brusquement est ce qu'on sait
en listant sur dix ans c'est pas la
mauvaise c'est intéressant parce que
vous ramenez les politiques à une
question de style à une différence de
forme vous ne diriez plus aujourd'hui
deux choses d'abord
à quel point j'étais mal habillée c'est
j'ai un peu hot rétrospectivement
première chose deuxième chose
[Musique]
nous sommes en 95 vous l'avais dit après
donc nous sommes trois ans après
maastricht après le référendum sur
maastricht après
si vous voulez je pense que ce que je
dis à l'époque et est tout à fait
conforme à la réalité c'est à dire qu'à
partir de maastricht il n'y a plus de
vraie différence entre la droite et la
gauche
vous savez vous connaissez le mot
célèbre de philippe séguin la droite et
la gauche sont des
dés
comment dire des comment il disait des
boutiques et où des dans des dédales des
détaillants qui se fournissent au même
grossiste l'europe donc ce que j'ai
voulu dire là c'est ça c'est à dire que
l'europe la construction européenne
maastricht
les les pertes de souveraineté que cela
a occasionné la mondialisation tout cela
rares
fait ressembler les politiques fait à se
rapprocher les cons les politiques et
que tout est question de forme donc
effectivement pourquoi je ne le dirais
plus aujourd'hui je ne le dirais plus
aujourd'hui non pas parce que c'est faux
puisque sur les politiques économiques
franchement ça n'a jamais été aussi vrai
et d'ailleurs tous les français ont fini
par se rendre compte de cela je me
rappelle que déjà dans la campagne de
2002 jean pierre chevènement disait
chose rack pour dire jospin et chirac
c'était la même chose
donc c'est une réalité qui a petit à
petit petit à petit s'est imposé on sait
bien que françois hollande a été très
critiqué à gauche parce qu'il faisait
finalement la même politique que la
droite et la droite a été très critiquée
aussi par ce que il faisait la même
politique que la gauche donc je dirais
toujours cela mais en revanche la
nouveauté et c'est sans doute le
justement le sens de ma candidature
c'est que je pense que nous sommes
sortis de la discussion économique et
que nous sommes rentrés dans la
discussion identitaire c'est à dire que
ce n'est plus la question n'est plus
comme depuis l'après guerre jusqu'aux
années 90 comment on répartit la
richesse comment on répartit la
croissance plus ou moins comment l'état
intervient plus ou moins dans l'économie
bref on est sorti d'une discussion
économique et social
comprenez-moi bien ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'ya plus de questions économiques
il n'y a plus de questions sociales il
s'agit de tout ça existe encore mais
comme comme coeur selon moi de la vie du
pays c'est la question identitaire qui
se pose la question de la survie de la
france de la question du grand
emplacement toutes ces questions que
j'ai posées dans cette présidentielle et
qui pour moi vont déterminent le destin
de la france dans les décennies à venir
[Musique]